du bébé gastronomes à la nutrition
plaisir et santé dès l'enfance
les thématiques d'ouverture de la 4ème
édition des universités du goût
organisée aux fermes de gally les
nourrissons au coeur des échanges avec
le public et des questions sur les
comportements alimentaires à adopter
c'est un rendez vous annuel de réflexion
pour moi réflexion sur ce que je mange
sur ce que je fais manger à mes amis à
mes enfants
ça m'apporte énormément j'ai appris que
l'allaitement était quand même très
favorables sur le goût et la mémoire du
goût et l'initiation du goût chez les
enfants des spécialistes en médecine en
neurosciences ou des agriculteurs
différentes disciplines pour parler de
la mémoire du goût des souvenirs qui se
construisent dès l'enfance avec des
astuces pour faire aimer certains
aliments comme les légumes les enfants
sont rigoureusement de bonnes soupes et
de bons légumes à bons légumes se
présentent pas dans une assiette comme
ça fige et sans sauce
il faut jouer avec le légume et l'enfant
est donc là les enfants ensuite auront
l'habitude ci le prenne dès leur
première aliments comme on l'a expliqué
que ce soit dans la terra tueur ce soit
dans les arts où je sois dans la cuisine
il est très important à un moment donné
qui a un rapport aux cons se souviennent
du haut doubs on vient et on se souvient
d'où on vient quand le moment donné on
se souvient de sa première mediène de sa
première bière parler ou potes du
premier biscuit qu'on aime qu'on a pu
qu'on a pu avaler des souvenirs
permettant de se construire une culture
nutritionnelle une culture en constante
évolution à mettre en harmonie entre
santé et plaisir alimentaire